what's the deal with airplane
peanuts welcome back to the joke World
comedy news update today's story Shane
Gillis is officially moving to Austin
Texas it's the new comedy Hub this new
information was revealed Sunday night
during a live taping of the real ass
podcast in Austin Texas featuring LS J
Gomez and Zach Amo that episode won't be
public until Saturday night but included
a tremendous list of special guests
Shane Gillis Ari shafir Mark Norman Tony
Hinchcliffe and Brian Redban witnessing
this lineup together all on the same
podcast was nuts it seemed like every 20
minutes a new special guest was added to
the panel there was plenty of funny
moments but the most interesting Moment
by far was when Lis J Gomez asked Shane
Gillis about his plans to move to Texas
at first it seemed like a joke and Lewis
was just busting balls with Shane
because he had already [__] on Austin a
few different times earlier in this
episode but to the whole audience's
surprise he confirmed the news was
indeed true Shane Gillis will be the
next great comedian to move to Austin
Texas but not for the reasons you might
think we might have to break out of the
New York Matrix yeah that' be tight
could be time dude could be we'll see
yeah it could be we'll see true stay
tuned stay tuned stay tuned gotcha going
to Alaska we're moving to Alaska that
would be awesome it's the new comedy Hub
Alaska
Juno just get ripped apart by bears at
first glance the reason why one of the
top comedians in the world would move to
Austin Texas right now seems pretty
obvious the comedy scene there is
absolutely exploding unlike anything
we've ever seen before but that's not
the only thing about the Lone Star State
that caught Shane's eye Shane Ari and
Tony Hinchcliffe all showed up to this
900 p.m. taping after day drinking with
Ric Flair since 1 p.m. so the boys were
smashed so it makes sense why Shane was
a bit Cy at first about admitting one of
the reasons he's moving to Texas might
be for the no state income tax during
the podcast he seemed to think saying
that out loud might be frowned upon but
as red ban pointed out seconds later
taxes are a completely legitimate reason
to live in a new place and probably
played a factor as to why Joe Rogan left
California and started this whole
movement in the first place yeah people
are really worried about all folks like
me moving from uh California yeah
worried worried about you know what's
funny is that come one come all give me
your tired you're poor come on to Texas
but you got to understand something yeah
you're coming here because of low taxes
and low regulation and you want to live
your life in Liberty and make sure that
you can protect yourself and protect
your family and that means you have to
you have to vote a certain way and
that's why we kind of are our Texas
don't turn this place into what you fled
that's exactly right right that's what
Matthew mccon was telling that's exactly
right well we have to kind of put that
out there toact right and I understand
people have different views and whatnot
but you're here for a reason yeah Shane
Gillis has been taking off the last few
years reaching new levels of popularity
and fame every single day so any
money-saving decision like relocating to
Texas makes tons of logical sense
especially since he just signed his
first deal with Netflix for his new
special beautiful dogs which came out
today of course the obvious question on
every comedy Fan's mind right now is
what's happening with the podcast and
will Matt mccusker be following Shane
Gillis to Texas the truth is we don't
know yet it seems safe to assume that
Matt would come with Shane to Austin and
be part of the special movement
happening down there but Matt's life is
a little different than Shane's the
shaman has a wife and kids and doesn't
even currently spend all his time in New
York City it's definitely going to be
interesting to see how this all plays
out but hopefully they can keep
recording the podcast together in person
if that's not possible I'm sure they
could still make something work long
distance even if it means more guest
episodes like we've seen with two bears
one cave when their host started Living
in different cities which actually
brings us to our next segment guest
spots from last week The Joe Rogan
Experience had on Bill Maher two bears
one cave was Burton Tom Tom and Bert
killed Tony this week with with Joe D
roza and David Lucas flagrant hat on
Logan Paul Matt and Shane secret podcast
did not have an episode Joe list was on
are you garbage Joe was also on the
Honeydew taste buds battled sleeping
naked vers pajamas Carrot Top was on
Whiskey Ginger and why mhat on Mark
Norman but he is right like if you would
just want to annihilate a woman you if
you slept with her best friend that's
kind of the ultimate I don't think
there's anything worse than that you're
devastated dude decent advice I so I
don't think that's just for women I mean
like a woman could do that to a man it's
pretty devastating would that would ruin
a human being I think you're done right
totally godamn dude dude you know what
you should do what
Bert that be so awesome that would be so
cool thanks babe yeah this past weekend
with Theo Von talked with Jordan
Peterson the Tim Dylan show had on
jannis papus bad friends talked with the
bus and with the boys boys the Blox
podcast had on Jud APO Josh Potter was
on first date take your shoes off with
Rick Glassman had on Ari shafir and
Jordan Jensen Adam Corolla was on the
Harland Highway Russell Peters was on
you know what dude Josh Johnson was a
guest on Chrissy chaos tiger belly had
on Dan Soder and Bill Burr had a live
taping of the Monday Morning podcast
that is currently available on his
YouTube channel as far as new standup
specials that are either out right now
or coming out soon everyone knows this
by now but Shane Gill's beautiful dogs
is out on Netflix go stream it right now
and sound off in the comments what you
think we'll be putting together
subscriber responses for a reaction
video coming out soon on this channel
Shane wasn't the only comedian with a
new special coming out on Tuesday Louis
J Gomez also released his 30-minute
stand up on YouTube the same day as
Shane Buddy congrats on the special
congrats to guest digital you're
producing a bunch of [__] specials
you got them cooking yeah I'm I'm pumped
it was six of us that did them we did
six half hour specials over the course
of three nights it was uh Dave Smith
first Kurt Meers just came out last week
M's out today officially um and then
next week is colum turle Jordan Jensen
and then Rich Voss they're all
incredible comedians very different very
different perspectives just kind of like
it was really a great group and um happy
how they came out they were [__]
great dude it's awesome and I've always
said this of you while you know you
ruffle some feathers from time to time
with a lot of people you have done more
for New York comedians Endor comedy as a
whole than [__] anybody stop it it's
how it's I have a pool now it's all for
me it's nothing it has nothing to do
with anybody
else I know I have goals in mind and
very often some of those goals the
peripheral benefit is that I get to work
with some of the best comedians in the
world and create amazing projects with
we also have Davey Jackson The Cult kid
out on YouTube as well as Joe list
enough for everybody which apparently
Joe's special was demonetized and
restricted in some way by the platform
so go check that out right now and try
to give it as much support as possible
so yeah being suppressed so please go
watch it spread the word fight the power
maybe I'll be one of these guys you know
like these uh these grifters wow the
people that are like I they they got me
right you know help me out or whatever
yeah you'll be at the capital in a year
cuz Schultz he I mean he blew up cuz he
he was on Barry Weiss because he had to
change something or something too
offensive some streamer wouldn't have
him whatever the story is but he made a
cool five mil because of it all right
I'll make five mil yes why not there's
also a few specials in the chamber that
will be coming out relatively soon Ari
shaffir and big J oakerson taped two
crowdwork shows together in New York
City last weekend that should be highly
entertaining if you enjoy crowd work in
other news Ralph Barbosa has filmed his
new special no word on when that will be
coming out yet but it will will be on
Netflix obviously there is a lot
happening in the comedy and podcasting
world right now people like Shane Gillis
are moving to different states Joey deas
and Lee sayia might be getting back
together for good the regs has a new
episode out now people's specials are
getting demonetized we'll have videos
coming out this week on all of these
topics and more right here on this
channel joke world as well as our second
Channel clip world so if you like comedy
and you're still watching this video you
might as well become a subscriber make
it official thanks for
watching @ joke
world that's did it joke
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out